[Music]
there are a lot of white people here
today don't I got a tailor to settle a
little bit now here we go there's a lot
of white people I like white people they
invented brunch that's great
nobody at that market corner before you
guys shout out to white people huh well
as I get older I do a lot of white
people things like I said I like brunch
but what's wider than that as I write
you up the views about the brunch I go
to I go wine tasting some of my white
friends as if you go wine tasting for
any other type of French right I got
wine tasting with my friends but I
realize some of my friends are full of
crap you know because it's a male go ask
my wife friends what they taste another
like I taste floral notes and hints of
honey cloves of garlic and sunshine and
rainbows and they're like Quincy would
you taste I'm like red red I'm drunk I'm
drunk obviously this is a great reason
to day drink though good job you guys
like romantic comedies I don't I don't
because it's the same old plot right
it's about a uptight businesswoman in a
laid-back guy therefore my opposite
sides of the track how they're gonna
make it work
how are they gonna make it work and
that's it well I wrote my own screenplay
it's a little more reality based it's
called two people dating in LA with no
car
she lives in Reseda he lives in Encino
there's no train how are they gonna make
it work how they're gonna make a work I
don't like people who wear Community
College sweatshirts I don't they're a
little too cocky in life and I don't
know why like don't you get your
bachelors in your rack the apparel you
know Zane don't celebrate prematurely
with your LACC sweatshirt expecting me
to be in France we've got two more years
to go finish strong I went to subway
recently I'm just bragging and I don't
know about you guys but I go to Subway
for the cookies that's why I go to Eric
for the cookie
I get three types cookies I get white
chocolate macadamia net I get chocolate
chip I get a man M we throw it in a bag
go to a cashier registers that can
antigen anything else I might like what
I got everything I need right here in
this bag he's like what about a flat
teacher I'm like what what is the flat
teacher
it's like it's a personal pan pizza I'm
like oh but you guys barely make
sandwiches correctly
I like to drink I like to drink but I
don't like to get drunk and get phone
numbers because that's dangerous for me
see I get too drunk and I forget the
girl's name and I throw my phone as a
place that I remember like I was going
through my phone on her way here tonight
and there's a girl my phone called
McDonald's hookup chick I'm confused I
don't know what that means I don't know
if we met at McDonald's and hooked up or
if she works at McDonald's and she hooks
it up you guys know what my problem with
the police is no you know my problem the
cops are besides I'm killing black
people
you guys know my problems it's they're
never around when you need them you know
you know when you're driving down the
freeway late at night you see that BMW
fly by doing 110 you're like someone
should give that guy a ticket when I got
to thinking what what cops do be able to
be applied to any other job description
probably not
what's your name sir Dustin yeah let's
say I hired Dustin to do a job right and
Dustin is never around when I need him
right
and then Dustin doesn't do it as job
description says right and then Dustin
kills people
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we'd all agree Dustin isn't a good
barista right have a question on saying
guys so much
[Applause]
you